l'action ça tout bas on va essayer de
faire un nouvel épisode d'un changer de
tenue c'est plus les terres d'ailleurs
tu sais quel jour on est on est de 13
octobre
ouais alors de quoi on parle se passe
quelque chose de 13 octobre
me wade est un génie bonjour nous sommes
le 13 octobre et il ya exactement sept
cent huit ans était arrêté tous les
templiers de france à cette occasion
nous reviendrons sur leur création leur
parcours et leur destruction
en fait c'était l'anniversaire de ta
mère j'avais pas pour les templiers
ok mais on va tenter de faire un épisode
sur
je précise tout de suite que nous nous
intéresserons ici aux faits historiques
et nour nombreuses les gens qui
circulent sur les templiers
si vous vous intéressez au complot sur
le trésor des templiers nicolas sketchs
vous renseignera mieux que moi si vous
êtes un fan des rois maudits nous
verrons que cette histoire repose sur du
n'importe quoi et si vous êtes bloqués
dans assassin's creed sauter dans une
botte de paille et laissez moi vous
raconter l'histoire des templiers tels
que vous ne l'avez jamais entendue tout
commence avec les croisades même si à
l'époque on parle plutôt de pèlerinage
le terme de croisade apparaissant pour
la première fois au xvème siècle à la
fin du xième siècle la terre sainte est
une destination très prisée pour les
chrétiens d'occident qui rêvent de
passer leurs vacances à se prélasser
dans les lieux saints de jérusalem
malheureusement pour eux l'endroit est
très mal fréquenté depuis quelques temps
puisqu'il a été conquis par les turcs
eux seldjoukides qui s'en donnent à
coeur joie pour inquiéter voire
assassiner les pauvres chrétiens qui
voulait juste voir du pays
le but de la première croisade et donc
de redonner l'accès aux lieux saints
rappellera et si possible de conquérir
ses terres tout simplement jérusalem est
donc présent en 1099 ce qui permet la
création des états latins d'orient et
des templiers dans tout ça j'y arrive
après la prise de jérusalem plusieurs
ordres religieux se met en place
les chamans du saint sépulcre s'occupe
des affaires religieuses dans le sang
les chrétiens en 2006 et en 1113 et créé
l'ordre de l'hôpital qui s'occupe de
protéger le chanoine et de la charité
les hospitaliers sont un peu débordées
et hub de peignes qui n'arrive en terre
sainte quelques années après la première
croisade à l'idée de créer un nouvel
ordre qui se fume près uniquement de la
protection des chanoines et des pèlerins
en route vers jérusalem en 1120 est donc
reconnue par l'église la milice des
pauvres chevaliers du christ et du
temple de salomon
un ordre la fois religieux et militaire
je croyais qu'on allait parler les
templiers
ce sang des templiers le roi de
jérusalem besoin de leur permet de
s'installer dans une partie de son
palais qui correspond à l'emplacement du
temple de salomon selon l'ancien
testament
ah mais c'est pour ça qu'on les appelle
templiers oui bon au début ils ont peu
de personnel leur tout petit budget
alors ils se contentent de surveiller un
défilé le défilé date vite dans lequel
les pèlerins étaient souvent pris en
embuscade par des bandits ensuite une de
taille de son compagnon godefroy de
saint-omer décide de rentrer en occident
pour une grande tournée visant à faire
la promotion de leurs ordres bonjour
pourriez nous vous parler de notre ordre
religieux parviennent à se faire
reconnaître par le pape insafe ce qui
leur permet de devenir l'ordre religieux
à rejoindre
vous aimez vous battre mais vous songez
aussi une carrière religieuse
n'hésitez plus avec les templiers vous
pourrez combiner vos deux passions
mais comment fonctionne cet ordre et
comment devenir templiers
prenant l'exemple de cette jeune fille
pardon ce jeune homme il devra prononcer
trois bleus pauvreté chasteté obéissance
à tanger tétouan le deuxième vingt il
peut être aussi bien noble ou simple
pécore où il doit avoir plus de 18 ans
ne pas être fiancé ne pas être engagé
dans un autre ordre ne pas être
excommunié néant
ne pas être sert s'engager pour la vie
et être en parfaite santé physique et
mentale ça va je peux rester
on va dire que ça passe tu as aussi
l'interdiction de mentir en dehors du
fait que je suis une femme que tu viens
de référendum tout même comme dans tout
ordre religieux des templiers été soumis
à une hiérarchie avec à leur tête de m
qui était responsable de l'ensemble des
commanderies de leur pays et à leur tête
se trouver un maître général qui était
désigné avec des templiers obtiennent
leur propre drapeau en 1147 et n'en
déplaise à ridley scott il est stipulé
dans leurs règles qu'ils avaient les
cheveux coupés ras annonces la chasteté
ok mais pas les cheveux les templiers
s'avèrent des combattants redoutable
face aux arabes et en 1129 et s'intègre
l'armée du roi ne se contentent donc pas
de protéger les pèlerins mais prennent
part aux grandes batailles entre les
francs et les arabes comme la bataille
de hattin qui est montré dans le film
kingdom of heaven et qui se termine en
grosse défaite pour les francs tous les
templiers présents sont faits
prisonniers par amel de saladin et ils
sont tous exécutés et tu voulais montrer
qu'ils étaient de bons combattants c'est
ça dans d'autres occasions ils ont été
forts
comme source de revenus les templiers
reçoivent des dons dans un premier temps
puis s'enrichissent en accordant des
prêts à des personnes allant du simple
croisé au roi de vente sans devenir la
banque templière cette petite activité
leur permet de vivre confortablement le
roi louis 7 a tellement confiance en
dieu qu'ils confient aux templiers de
marie la garde de son trésor royal alors
qu'il part en croisade
il est imité par ses successeurs et par
le roi henri ii d'angleterre
on a beaucoup parlé de la fortune des
templiers mais la plus grande partie de
leur richesse venait de biens fonciers
des monastères en occident et des
forteresses en orient point donc de
merveilleux trésors cachés ni de grave
défendue par les templiers
de toute façon le graal c'est un local à
un choix non c'est une invention
arthurienne t'es bizarre
malheureusement la perte de saint jean
d'âcre en 1291 oblige les chrétiens à
quitter la terre sainte
c'est la fin d'une époque pour les
templiers dans le ciel j'ai transféré à
chypre mais en l'absence de pèlerins à
protéger on commence à s'interroger sur
leur rugby
plusieurs facteurs expliquent leur chute
lors inutilité d'abord depuis la perte
de la terre sainte le 6 le fait que
certains vivaient dans une certaine
richesse qui éveillait les jalousies et
enfin le roi philippe iv le bel est en
conflit avec le pape et craint un petit
peu cette armée de 15 mille heures
entièrement douloureux à ce dernier
il profite donc des confessions d'un
ancien templiers qui prétend que ses
confrères se livrent à des activités peu
commune pour lancer un ordre
d'arrestation le 13 octobre 1307 le jour
même de l'anniversaire de la reine ça
devient palpitant très peu de temps plié
en réchappe
la plupart sont enfermés et puisqu'il
s'agit d'un ordre religieux philippe
lebel ne peut pas juger lui-même
il fait donc appel à son confesseur le
grand inquisiteur de france pour mener à
bien les opérations et quelle opération
puisque sous la torture de nombreux
heures d'autres confessent des actes des
résident idolâtrie d'un dieu n'appelez
pas faux mais de sodomie mais on peut
comprendre que vu les moyens employés il
aurait été prêt à confesser n'importe
quoi j'ai tué mufasa suite à ce procès
se déroulant sur plusieurs années le
pape intervenants plusieurs reprises
pour essayer de calmer les choses
beaucoup de templiers sont condamnés au
bûcher d'autres retourner à la vie
civile mais tous leurs biens sont
transférés à l'ordre des hospitaliers
mais tout n'est pas si mal puisque le
pape clément 5 absoute secrètement les
dirigeants de l'ordre ils sont quand
même mort mais ils ont été pardonnés peu
de templiers sont arrêtés dans les
autres pays d'europe
leurs biens sont confisqués mais ils
sont également absous l'ordre des
templiers est définitivement aboli en
1312 n'a donc duré qu'un peu moins de
200 ans mais il a continué de nourrir
l'imaginaire à tel point qu'on le
retrouve encore dans de nombreuses
oeuvres de fiction mais aussi dans
certains ordres religieux actuelle qui
se réclament des templiers et je termine
cette vidéo en apportant la malédiction
des templiers prononcé par jacques de
molay le dernier maître de l'ordre qui
auraient mode il pas pour le roi où les
deux jusqu'à la treizième génération la
13e génération du pape ya eu tellement
de versions cette histoire montre où la
première trace en 1548 soit plus de deux
siècles après les événements il s'agit
seulement d'une légende pour tuer la
troupe le supposer que les derniers mots
de jacques de molay ont plutôt été oh oh
ah ça brûle ou je ne sens plus mes
mollets jacques de molay merci
il y aurait beaucoup de choses à dire
sur les templiers la manière dont ils
s'habillaient dont il se battait le
déroulement leur procès j'espère que cet
aperçu vous a intéressé et si vous
voulez en savoir plus
alain de murger a écrit plusieurs livres
sur le sujet merci d'avoir regardé et à
la prochaine
et trouvez pas quelque chose